[Musique]
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
jennifer prend sa mission de coach de
the voice all star très à coeur j'ai
craqué alors que la partie des cross
battles a débuté dans l'émission les
coaches assiste désormais à des combats
médicaux de plusieurs de leurs talents
et pour eux il est parfois difficile de
voir leur poulain qui telle aventure de
façon parfois injuste et pas très
agréable de faire tout en jeux d'hiver a
particulièrement mal vécu les règles du
jeu n'hésitant pas à menacer la
production et la chaîne de quitter
prématurément le programme
en cause une battle entre deux artistes
à l'issue de laquelle ali a été éliminée
et dont jennifer n'envisagez pas du tout
le départ à ce stade de la compétition
[Applaudissements]
contre la production de the boys qui
n'est pas très habituel de la part des
coaches d'habitude plutôt docile alors
je vole ce all star jennifer en colère
contre la production ou choquer
personne
elle est l est pas l a pas du tout été
en plus elle n'est pas du tout en guerre
avec la production pour avoir eu
quelqu'un de la production hier au
téléphone ils sont absolument pas en
guerre elle a juste était déçu
finalement de perdre son talent elle a
eu les boules sur le moment mais c'est
tout enfin se passe on d'alembon ccdh
alors oui enfin résultat le reste du
monde il aurait à magna ça fait très
bonne figure est ce un talent mais y'a
pas en tout cas elle n'est pas fâché
avec la production s'entendent super
bien il n'y a aucun problème est que la
prod et elle était juste déçu on peut
comprendre elle a quand même perdu
effectivement
gagné tous les jeux de télé l'emploi
[Rires]
je sens quand vous étiez
qui a quitté l'autre
moi aussi j'ai dix ans et trois fois
d'un commun accord c
pour ça non vous pensez que à la culture
perramant allait bien gagner quoi moi je
pars oui après façon sinon elle n'aurait
pas gagné star ac elle a dû façon s'il
en est là c'est parce qu'elle a du
tempérament mais je pense qu'après et le
tout si elle a vraiment très bien sûr et
surtout et elle habite au talent mais
après qu'elle dise à la production
qu'elles menacent sa production de
partir mais
c'est dans les dix ans je n'ai rien
contre elle a dit si c'est avéré c'est
un peu moyen est maintenant si elle n'a
pas dit bon dans la face à leur maire de
pâques mais je peux comprendre il faut
elle avait clamé avoir été assez
stratège alors comment on peut être
stratège don de vos six alors justement
jeu parce que la règle des cros battle
l'idée c'est trop tôt voilà en gros ce
matin là c'était la première fois qu'il
le veut est ce qu'en fait ce white star
a été enregistrée en novembre de l'année
dernière octobre novembre l'année
dernière c'était la toute première fois
ouh ouh c'était testé par les coaches et
en fait l'idée c'est que c'est le coach
qui doit décider que le talent il va
envoyer et l'autre choisi qui va envoyer
comme talent et donc du coup faut être
un peu stratégique viande on va même
effort mais je vais essayer de les
garder et pour les maîtres contre des
plus faibles pour être sûr de garder mon
talent sauf que jennifer quand elle est
arrivée comme cette règle n'existait pas
on lui a expliqué mais voilà il fallait
vraiment se penser stratégie un peu à la
koh lanta la même qu'il ya eu le plus
fort contre les écureuils assez pour les
noirs et
elle a aussi incriminé le public qui
croit cd enregistré en plein ça c'est
pas bien connu et pour que vmotion
public n'était pas un public de un peu
mes classiques mais des intermittents du
spectacle non en fait c'est impossible
si c'était sur toi lui dit qu'il n'était
pas prêt il est temps
[Rires]
c'était pas un public présent mais
effectivement derrière des écrans et
donc il ya des sensations qu'on a moins
forcément et quand vous regardez les
gens qui partent c'est quasiment que des
nanas oui donc en fait le public a
plutôt voté pour les garçons comme c'est
toujours le cas dans les télé crochets
mais c'est avec c'est un petit peu relou
quand on a super tarki pas simplement
parce que c'est une fille de veulent
voir venir qu'en maintenant la de grace
et tourne à l'obsession là ils
recommencent s'arrêtera donc jamais
mais c'est du harcèlement c'est vraiment
très bien s'est jamais bien où j'aime
bien
on sait bien c'est bien c'est une très
belle saison